oh yeah nug is a bug check it out dude
this is my god station C double OD god
berries but good yeah I heard when
people trip they like talk to God or
whatever one of God's a chick did big
old titties big old God titties yeah
yeah like ones that you must respect
absolutely
also Amanda list of questions she's
probably gonna want to ask me will Adam
how many girls have you slept
oh you think you're God bro you're not
God bro you can't ask me that sorry
fat six with five just kidding a hundred
right haha yeah I'm just trying to see
something way more real than God like a
dragon
that'd be sweet that's blasphemous sorry
oh hey ders bud here's your collar no
can do guys Alyce's buzz Miceli and
wants me to join her in West Covina for
a business convention and then you
explain to her that you can't because
you're doing acid we're doing drug right
we're doing a lot of drugs together guys
come on this is kind of a big deal for
me it's my first business trip right I'm
like Steve Martin in that John Candy
movie I thought you wanted to be like
Steve Jobs and do a bunch of acid with
us Steve Jobs right created Apple great
company but then he left and created
Pixar which is way better then he came
back to Apple made that way better we
got iPads iPhones all sorts of stuff let
me go create my Pixar then I'll come
back and we'll drop iPhones okay I have
no idea what any of that stuff meant no
and my Pixar we're doing acid
Oh Oh God ah okay Oh Gary
help me uh help me okay wish me luck
we're doing Elsa together some friends
and family dares
you